COLT MCANLIS: For many
game devs out there,
PNG image files are a backbone
of their development process,
but they also come with some
unintended side effects.
My name is Colt McAnlis.
And for savvy developers who are
concerned with user bandwidth
and download times,
PNG files may not
be the best choice
for your game assets.
And the truth is that
PNG files are everywhere
in mobile development.
After analyzing 1,000 of the
top games on Google Play,
it was discovered that PNG files
accounted for more than 75%
of all textures for those
games, which makes sense, right?
Developers are busy people.
And PNG files are easy to use,
support transparency, provide
some compression savings,
and they're available
cross platform.
But in a world with restricted
download times, customer
acquisition woes, and harsh
data caps, the size of your app
does matter.
And PNG files just
aren't going to cut it.
For developers looking
to reduce texture asset
footprint in their
game distribution,
the WebP image format
is a perfect replacement
for PNG files.
WebP supports most
of what game devs
love about PNG, that is,
transparency, cross platform
support, and
lossless compression.
But it also supports
lossy compression,
meaning you can get
even smaller file sizes.
And WebP fits into your
existing production pipeline
with plug-ins for Adobe
Photoshop, GIMP, ImageMagick,
and more.
Plus, the command line converter
allows you to batch convert
your asset chain during your
build phase, which is always
helpful for
programmers on the go.
Using WebP is easy in your
game, as it's accessible through
a C++ library that you can drop
into your existing code base,
allowing you to use it on
mobile and desktop platforms.
And it's also available
for the web as well.
To get a better sense of the
type of compression savings
available, the WebP
team ran some tests
to see how the format stacked
up against PNG, testing
1,000 images in a test corpus.
This graph shows the
normalized results.
You can see that
the optimized PNG
files are listed as the
1.0 green line there.
And it's direct to see that both
for lossy and lossless modes,
WebP files are consistently
smaller in size.
That odd little
spike at the end,
though, is caused by
one-by-one pixel images, which
you'd expect some weird
spikes to go on there.
Anyhow, this is a perfect
time to remind you
of a couple of tips of
getting the most out of WebP.
It's important to understand
that one compression
level doesn't work for
all images in your game.
Diffuse maps are different
than normal maps, which
are different than alpha
maps, which are specifically
different than highly
transparent UI images, which
means that finding the right
balance between image quality
and size means finding the
right types of compression
settings for each image.
But doing that for
every image in your game
could be impractical.
Instead, try to classify your
images based on their usage
type as this generally describes
their visual properties.
From here, you can
associate each usage bucket
with a specific set of
compression settings.
These settings can
easily be found
by your artists who
have a few hours
to kill on a Thursday afternoon.
Oh, and make sure to provide
a file that lists overrides
for specific images which may
require specific compression
settings that are different
than the bucket they actually
fall into.
Trust me, your
artists will love you
for this simple, little feature.
Now it's worth pointing out
that PNG and WebP files are not
GPU formats.
That is, when you decompress
them into main memory,
they will be in full 32-bits
per pixel and reside on the GPU
as such.
There's a whole set of
GPU compressed formats
out there, like DXT, ETC, PVR,
and ASTC, which exist on disk
and on GPU in
compressed format, which
means that you should
consider supporting GPU
formats alongside WebP ones for
textures that may support it.
This way, you can optimize
both your distribution
and GPU residency sizes.
Anyhow, to get
started with WebP,
hop on over to the development
page and grab the C++ SDK
for your game, or
read the docs online.
And make sure you check
out more information
on alpha blending that can
cause problems in your game
by checking out my other video,
"Don't Alpha That Pixel."
WebP is a perfect
replacement for bloated PNG
files in your app.
So go out there,
compress your textures,
and build better games.